we're basically using the EDSAC is a
classic example of a very early von
Neumann computer even to the great
credit of Cambridge I mean they did get
it working by I think it was April May
1949 something like that and it went on
to great glory afterwards and
calculations on there from many
Cambridge scientists I mean it's no
exaggeration to say Nobel Prizes were
won because of the availability of a
track in all sorts of areas we're gonna
take a look and try an answer this this
question of how on earth do you get this
wretched edge sack to boot up and with
the help of Martin Campbell Kelly's
emulator we're able to going to be able
to show you something of that because
what I want to do is to describe how the
initial boot programs first tablet it
was called initial orders one second law
establish called initial orders -
written by a really bright guy who was
the PhD student - Morris Wilkes who led
of the EDSAC team of course that chaps
name was David wheeler a really nice
chap I didn't know him only slightly but
he was fearfully bright and always good
for a chat about low-level issues like
this about how did you get this wretched
thing to work given that I suspect
inherited on edsac but feeding back into
early things again like Tommy flowers
his colossus how do you get a bit
pattern in here to tell it to do what to
do because if you once get the bit
pattern in the electronics the logic and
everything inside it will execute it
correctly that will have been checked
out but how do you get the wretched
things in and the answer certainly on
the Colossus machine was you used a set
of what we'll call a unit selectors to
set up the ones and zeros and by having
enough unit selectors plus usually a
sort of load lever to load it into the
current location in memory then you had
to have an automated way inside the
hardware of stepping on to the next word
to be load it
people like me didn't use unit selectors
but learnt this up when you booted up an
early pdp-11 even as late as the 60s and
70s
it wasn't Eunice left as it was hand
keys on front of the panel think we
shoul knows once or twice same thing up
for a Wan down for a zero boom boom one
bomb load another baton load another
pattern load is bad enough loading up a
little boot program it's unthinkable to
load in an entire multi kilobyte program
that way but on the basis of hand
switches and unit selectors in this case
yes these wonderful initial orders to
and initial orders warned were loaded in
from unit selectors once you've
downloaded Martin's emulator it comes
with a tutorial guide and it makes me
very clear in there but on the actual
edge sack when you want you to load
initial orders you just press a button
John is working here on the unit
selector units I talked about the boot
ROM or the initial instructions those
are coded by how is wired up these unit
selectors when the operator presses the
start button a rotor spins in here and
as it passes each set of contacts that
gets injection to the memory to download
the program to give some idea the
initial orders I think or about 42 words
not 42 K not 42 Meg like it might be on
a modern bias 42 words because memory
was fantastically freshest what was a
word then is that 16 word is well
actually was 18 bits in F sack but
basically yeah an 18-bit word could be
loaded in and you could load the whole
thing in by hand but you wouldn't want
to so here's the challenge then there's
all this memory here in mercury
available what you want is something
sitting down on the bottom of memory to
help you get bit patterns in off paper
tape okay so that will be your boot
program now that's the kind of thing
sitting
low memory which nowadays is the BIOS
and it's a heck of a site more
complicated than the initial orders one
so what David wheeler did furnish Lord
as one said just to get us started early
1949 I will write a set of initial
orders that sits there all the time and
other people's tapes that come along I
want to say two things to them first of
all please do not trample all over my
initial orders that have been pre-loaded
don't go into very low memory addresses
like zero and start trying to overwrite
it kill the program stone-dead but
starting from I think he finished at 42
with his initial orders but to allow for
future expansion I think the
recommendation was start off at location
64 in memory 64 and above you put your
program there
I will now help you load it because when
you put your paper tape in it will be my
initial orders one that is asking to
read your tape character by character
okay and initially in initial orders one
he said I will do the following if you
type a I know that a is a certain bit
pattern meaning add and I will put that
in the correct field of the correct word
for you you may then want to write an
explicit decimal number to be added like
10 to save your brain I will translate
your decimal numbers in your
instructions into binary so as two
things I'm doing for you is I'm
translating the opcode I'm translating
obviously decimal numbers into binary
and I am keeping track of where I'm
loading them for you into memory I will
start if you say start at 64 I'll start
at 64 and I'll put them in successively
one after the other so far it sounds to
me like he's doing the job of a modern
CPU with registers and an interpreter to
interpret the code yeah it's like a very
elementary assembler but whereas with
assembly it's a two-part process you run
the assembler then you've got your
binary here you're using assembly codes
to make your own binary on-the-fly
a great-grandfather of the operating
system though oh yeah
the great-great great-grandfather the
operation system first of all we are
starting with a loader because that's
all this is it loads into memory but
it's very crude initial orders one right
what drove people mad about it was that
unfortunately you had to be in control
of your addresses because if your
program said jump to location 70 you
started 64 fine but what happens if you
want to intervene a few more orders a
few more instructions between 64 and 70
you've got to a halt to all the
addresses in your program because what
was at 70 where you wanted to go to is
now at 76 so you've got to go and say
don't jump to 70 jump to 76 so although
it was a loader it couldn't do anything
much about being a tall adaptive or
helping you to relocate as it was called
so this was realized very quickly that
any alteration to your program in for
changing all your addresses on the tape
so initial orders to David wheeler
became celebrated for the computer
science world for this he only in his
life ever published in left and papers
did David but he was still an FRS that's
how much he was rated I remember meeting
donk North once saying you know who have
you met recently what you've been doing
I said I saw David not DJ wheeler he
said you know RESP ect initial orders -
I mean yes David was really celebrated
for this it seems obvious now but it
certainly was not obvious at the time
everybody Wow
your initial orders - is going to help
us be able to alter the program and just
feed the tape in again without changing
all of the addresses all we have to do
is to change the load point at the top
say or something like that
maybe we don't want to put it at 64 we
want to put it somewhere else but what
David Wheeler said
so long as you threw out your orders
indicate and flag up to me the addresses
that we'll need changing I will keep
track of them and I will alter them for
you are these like variables then yeah
they basically it was it was doing what
modern assemblers can do anyway but very
early on saying no matter where you
choose to place this in memory you might
want to put it at one to eight oh two
five six or anywhere just tell me and I
will load it there and I will fix up all
the addresses you can just sort of say
like zero one two if you like but I will
add on sixty-four to them or 128 having
ontem or whatever you want all you must
do is flag up to me the addresses that
need to be altered in a special way that
my initial orders understand and it just
revolutionized the use of edsac because
what of course every computer scientist
wants to do and admittedly this was not
done in 1949 it was done recently is get
your computer to say hello world
well it's contributed program here that
for the sake of brevity just gets it to
say hi and perhaps you want to run hi
first and then say how the heck does
initial orders to enable this to be
loaded in and to work correctly so here
we go then this is the program that will
first of all load when I say start start
loads the program that is showing your
window on the left it is loaded in the
high program however with my heart
fading memory of edsac codes I can see
that the third instruction said F means
stop that was a very common trick to use
as an ad sack program is make it stop in
its execution early on because then you
can check in your peep your peephole
into the tanks does it look plausible
does all of this stuff here look like a
binary interpretation of all your
elementary assembler op codes and people
would know what to see oh they know what
to say oh yes you can look in there
saying oh looks like an ad instructor
me yes so there we are now that's
stopped here but what you can now do is
to single-shot it those of you again
assembly will now you often have a
single-shot capability for debugging
this is like a step through is it yeah
just to step through but the bit of luck
single ep ah got a cursor now if i
single EP again look it's printing the
letter H single-shot again hi so I think
one of the exercises in March ins
instructions I encourage you all to do
it just to get it to actually say hello
world just made a bit longer but here
when we look at the program we can see
an awful lot of what is actually
happening here it's saying stop but then
he goes on to actually outputting the
message how does it do it it uses an O
output instruction and that is part of
the EDSAC opcode it basically means
punch this to tape which is a way it
would have come out initially with this
@ symbol that was one of the signals to
david wheelers initial orders this is a
relative address not an absolute one and
I want you to adjust it for me
and because the writer top we've said at
t 64 K for assembler programmers that's
like saying org origin equals 64 in many
assemblers but here it's starting point
at 64 but look at this
o 5 @ symbol means output the thing that
is five locations beyond where I
currently am the app says you've got to
add on the base line now to the 569 so
down here then what it does first of all
is it outputs star F that is the code
that says turn into letter shift now if
you go back and watch my previous five
hold paper tape program you'll find that
whether it's Bordeaux cold or edsac code
you have to make sure if you want to
print out letters be doubly sure you are
in letter
shift not in Figure shift and vice-versa
otherwise it will all look like junk so
here is the code in that cycle says turn
me into left and make sure next
instruction beyond here says output the
thing that is six beyond this location
when you look there right it just says H
F so in other words the letters H and I
that are to be output are being picked
up as a data from instructions further
down and are being output by using this
memory relocation capability so that's
all you have to do is to put down
asterisk is shortcut in edsac for saying
switch the letter shift print the letter
h print the letter i but it's all done
very carefully by adjusting these
addresses here to actually be 69 70 and
71 in real life and if you do that you
then say output the bit button that is
in 69 it's a change to let your shift
request do the one in 70 it's the letter
H because I've planted out there so on
so I hope that if you work through that
very painfully you can see that just
that ability to use relative offsets
yeah
rather than absolute addresses means
that you the amount of rewriting of your
program just because it gets bigger can
be greatly minimized so what is initial
orders to is arguably the world's first
elementary relocating loader it is
keeping your program well away from
trampling on initial orders too but it's
relying on initial orders to for
translation a firm doesn't even need to
translate opcodes into binary they are
binary binary to decimal conversion and
now relocation all done for you and all
in much less than 64 words so that's why
so celebrated
this empty rack is one we haven't
started very much work on yet this would
have been the circuits to drive the
paper tape reader and the teleprinter we
do have a Tele printer and we do have a
tape reader
we've been driving those using a modern
computer to test them out we've now got
to design the interface circuits that
fit here